erratic ohmygosh miserable it's always
bad scale one to ten probably a lot an
eight I'll give it like a nine it's
obnoxious
Chicago's traffic congestion is
obnoxious but would you believe it's
getting to be as obnoxious as LA's when
I hear that I think I hopefully will be
living in Scottsdale or Miami by then
well today the average Windy City
commuter spends seventy hours per year
stuck in traffic
that ties Washington DC for the worst in
the nation and yeah it's even worse than
LA it's like the same amount of time you
spend on vacation every year you spend
stuck in traffic if you're a typical
computer in Chicago and if you think
things are bad now just wait Chicago has
a twenty five-year plan that says in 25
years we will have spent billions of
dollars and everything will be worse
there is no fun and sitting in traffic
great is my blood pressure
something that will usually to keep some
15 minutes to get somewhere it takes you
an hour stress and wasted time too awful
effects of traffic congestion but there
are many others by a whole slew of
economic and personal measures
congestion is much worse than people
realize imagine this is you and your car
the circle represents the amount of
ground you can get to in a reasonable
amount of time say 30 minutes the dots
represent all the possible jobs you
could apply for the bigger your
opportunity circle the better chance you
have of landing a great job but in
Chicago in many other cities opportunity
circles are shrinking because traffic
congestion is growing if it gets any
worse than what it is now I have to
start looking for somewhere else to work
smaller opportunity circle strength
businesses to the circle within the city
that they can expect customers to come
from the worst congestion is the smaller
that circle is the work at a restaurant
where a 90% of our business is pre
theater and so people are coming in from
the suburbs to see the show and they're
always late late comers may skip the
trip downtown entirely if gridlock keeps
getting worse but what if we could get
traffic moving think about it how would
your life change if you could get to
places quickly spend more time at home
rather than on the road I could probably
get more done in a day
be able to
or asleep I have to work out afterward
if I could get down here quicker then I
could work out before work and I have
more to do with my day afterwards
because I must do it
Demetrios Mike's is also a working
student he heads home from his job as a
postal worker right in the middle of
rush hour but check out how fast he's
going me it saves you about hour and a
half to do our he's talking about this
the 91 Express Lanes in Orange County
California with the extra bandwidth I do
my school work
don't talk to my plan and relax the
Express Lanes our toll roads that were
built right next to the regular lanes so
drivers can choose to use them or not
tolls are collected electronically and
the price of the toll goes up and down
depending on whether it's rush hour or
not the result is free-flowing traffic
if you have these toll lanes the buses
go in there for free and they're never
stuck in traffic because the price is
set to always keep those lanes
free-flowing so now you've got a better
transit option too and taxpayers didn't
foot the bill the Express lanes were
financed and built by a private company
and when there's no room on the surface
the same concept can go above ground or
tunnel underground as is common in
France England Australia and many other
nations so what about folks in Chicago
they're stuck on the Eisenhower and the
Kennedy and they're dreading having to
go through the spaghetti bowl and and
that's just you know that's just the
reality and other than paving them they
really haven't done anything to
alleviate the congestion so how about
something new finally fixing some of the
worst traffic snarls I would just like
to get people moving here's a new plan
that would do that build tunnels are
elevated lanes if there's no room on the
surface used pricing to keep traffic
flowing and get a private company to
build it and these ideas can work just
about anywhere because nationwide
there's so much private financing
available good news for cash-strapped
governments because the alternative is
pretty awful Travel will be worse it'll
take longer to get from here to there
they'll leave more people stuck on the
road it'll just be worse like so many
other cities chicago's current plan
spends billions and traffic gets worse
how about we have a plan to spend those
billions of dollars and have
transportation be better
you